heroes vs. aliens
the four night crossover event starts
with Supergirl Monday November 28th on
the CW hey youtubers it's Charlie so we
finally got some four night crossover
footage so I'm gonna do a breakdown
explain some of what's happening why
it's happening in some of the mechanics
behind it so here we go the noise I'm
Stephen Amell and Grant Gustin hey
everyone I'm Katie Lutz
I'm Brandon rouse
[Music]
this year in the crossovers and group
scenes were all and say yeah I got I go
to Twain the sandbox with almost
everyone it seems like
[Music]
if I could have someone on the Supergirl
team
I think we'd call Sara Lance if I could
have someone on the arrow team we bring
back Sara Lance
I'd take Supergirl we need more girl
power like I am into it
so definitely Supergirl that's true we
do anymore I know for Sara when she
meets Supergirl she's like a little
intimidated because she's so used to
being like the chick that has everything
under control and now all the sudden
there's like this alien that can
levitate and she's like okay I respect
you I see you you're kind of hot
that's how Sara feels I disregarded all
character direction when it came to all
of her interacting with Cara you did at
all times he's supposed to be matter and
I would just stared her longingly he
decided that very early on I did I told
that I told him that so I hope they may
have to cut around to that I immediately
hit her with the cold shoulder Yeah
right or just or just as as Oliver would
call it saying hello they never get to
work as much with the flash as I'd like
to Barry and Ray could be good friends
team flash wants Ray Palmer
[Music]
there's a ton of moments that I think
people will be really excited about
people that fight each other people that
interact I need you the episode I
blacked out I forget what happened yeah
I kind of forget what we're all there
though there's something you haven't
seen before which i think is pretty fun
so there was like a big promo shoot some
of it's a little tongue-in-cheek like
you see oliver reading Robinson Crusoe
while Barry and Cara play video games
Robinson Crusoe if you haven't read it
it's just a story about a man who gets
marooned on an island and then you see
caity lotz reading the invasion comic
book like she's actually reading the
story that's going to be happening
during the four night crossover so
they're just having a little bit of fun
and there were actual pictures from the
episode that teased a whole bunch more
stuff that you can't really pick out
which episode they fall in but you can
kind of guess based on the characters
that appear them like you see Sara on
Laurel here that might be during the
arrow episode but you have the
overarching story of the dominators
invasion that'll stretch over each
episode and then within each episode
you'll have a very flash centric story
you'll have a very arrow centric story
that's the hundredth episode of arrow 2
so there'll be a lot of deep cuts
happening during that but then they'll
resolve that on legends of tomorrow -
just because that's the last night so
even though it's just like a really
quick trailer they're just letting you
know this is all starting November 28th
that's a Monday Supergirl is only going
to lightly address it because it's in a
different universe Barry goes and gets
her brings her to the flash so November
29th that flash episode is really like
the beginning of the huge dominators
invasion storyline they said that the
Supergirl episode is only going to
lightly address it but obviously I'll be
doing videos for each of those for like
normally I haven't been doing Supergirl
episodes but I'll totally do a Supergirl
video as part of the four night
crossover so even though you have this
big invasion each of the episodes will
have like its own special flash centric
story that'll deal mostly with those
characters but obviously like part of
the fun of this is introducing Supergirl
to everyone because no one's met her
besides Barry yet so you have that then
you have all the extra arrow 100th
episode Easter eggs stuff happening
because they said it's going to be a big
love letter to the fans they did
everything they could to include every
big character that has ever been
featured
on the show that's Deathstroke that's
Walter that's Oliver his father so
there's gonna be so much stuff happening
in that episode in particular make sure
if you're not able to watch it that
night that you set your DVRs just
because it's going to be a really big
deal but the other big thing is
everybody's comic book costumes
especially Citizen steals it shows up in
this promo art here this is probably
from the fourth night of the crossover
so because we got that costume teaser
for killer frost and vibe we might not
see those in this episode but I wouldn't
be too surprised they just might be
misleading us with some of the way these
pictures look so let me know in the
comments do you think that everybody is
gonna get their comic book costume in
the four night crossover and what do you
think the big twist is going to be
because they did say that my control is
gonna have something to do with it like
you see flash and arrow here looking
like they're getting ready to fight
Diggle that's obviously some trick that
the dominators pull so there's really
like so much going on that we don't know
they'll probably release a couple more
trailers before the episode drops just
because it's a couple weeks away but
they are going to sync the episodes up
before that happens so that they happen
in the right order right now the flash
is an episode behind because of the u.s.
election that happened this week so
don't worry everything will happen in
the right order but I'll just post
updates on the schedule as we learn more
about that and the DC giveaway is still
going on right now I mean the four night
crossover trailer to you deal of course
there's gonna be a giveaway going on all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so well announce the winner when I
post my legends of tomorrow video which
will be my next video to post that'll be
on Friday morning so if you haven't seen
it Miami Vice reverse-flash Legion of
Doom probably one of the best episodes
they've had so far so be sure and watch
it well you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for my arrow
Prometheus dolph lundgren video and you
can click here to learn all about Young
Justice season 3 thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight